[Music]
welcome back to Hannity and we're
broadcasting tonight from the 193rd
special operations wing at the Air
National Guard base in Middletown
Pennsylvania
now WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange is
saying that he is proof that the
Russians did not give him the DNC emails
the last president Trump of his willing
to listen to what evidence Assange has
let's take a look I have identified and
I've even talked to this audio I've
never seen any one person face as much
in terms of attacks as you have you have
a media that's hostile you have
Democrats that are hostile you have
Republicans that are hostile a lot of
deep state that has been leaking on you
and one of the things that has come up
almost throughout your whole presidency
is this Russia Russia Russia Russia
obsession here's my question
I interviewed Julian Assange five times
I've talked to him other times he has
said it's not Russia
there was no collusion they didn't come
the DNC emails did not come from them
congressman Dana Rohrabacher met with
him and he says he has proof positive
evidence that would show the Trump
campaign never colluded with Russia he
just want is it in the best interest of
the country that if he has that
information that he should give it it
seems I'm guessing here he wants a
return to be left to law should the
country desert the country deserve to
know the truth that he has to know the
truth and also we can't let anybody play
around with our voters in our voter
system but I have to tell you this so
important
Russia was an excuse used by the
Democrats when they lost the election
they said they lost the election they
sat in a room and they said wow we look
bad the morning after X Factor it's been
written about I guess in various books
or a book but they said why did you lose
the election they said it was Russia
Russia wasn't Russia it was a bad
candidate it was a candidate that didn't
go to Wisconsin and Michigan have spent
tremendously more money than I did as
you know more than double and didn't do
well in Pennsylvania this great state
didn't do well in fly I mean lost
Wisconsin for the first time in decades
lost Michigan now with all of that being
said bad candidate but they said Russia
then they say ah
and it was Trump that colluded with
Russia I'm saying I did so look here's
the story and I think it's something but
this was an excuse by the Democrats and
people got carried away
this was a terrible and it's very bad
for our country what's happened because
I've been with Russia during this
campaign forget it forget it
this was an excuse that was used by the
Democrats it was an excuse for losing
election that frankly they should have
won because winning the electoral
college is so easy for a Democrat you
have to they start off with three major
states and to win the electoral college
for Democrats almost like a given that's
why people said you cannot get to 270
well we got to 306 okay because we won
but I thought it was very sad when I saw
this because they're using excuses and
you know one other thing I have to say
the electro couch I never appreciated I
always I would rather have a popular
vote for me it's easier because you go
to different states for me the popular
vote is easier but the one thing about
the electoral couch it takes you around
to the states that you would not go to
otherwise so it's been a great thing but
I'd say this we had an unbelievable
unprecedented election it was I'm so
proud of my people I'm so proud of you
you know I did this show when a lot of
people said well I did it a lot yeah a
lot of people I guess people are
watching like the one that since you've
been president but I'm glad to have you
open a lot of people that say maybe we
won't do it anymore with them you have
been so great and I'm very proud of you
and you know I'm a ratings person you
notice I always [ __ ] okay has anyone
seen his writing what you are doing to
your competition is incredible number
one and I'm very proud of you and it's
an honor to be in the show I have to
tell you that judge the president I
think I remember one time we had an
early early conversation and I'm going
to end the interview on this and this is
how I've always felt I just I haven't
you said well you know I have all these
things and maybe you want to play golf
on my course one day you said this
before long before we were friends
before you ever ran for office right and
then when you ran I just said I only
want one thing help our country let's
help the Forgotten men and women let's
keep this country safe and I think
that's our prayer for you and
[Applause]
and also tonight before President Trump
speech I had a chance to speak to the
crowd and ask them what they think about
the Trump administration Congress the
liberal media and so much more
watch this have you met the president I
have met the President had a couple
rally sure how do you feel the job he's
doing Congress is doing in the media
well I first of all the media we're not
even going to talk about because it's a
waste of time because they don't report
anything fairly in terms of the job that
the president's doing Congress needs to
get on board and realize
Donald Trump love him or hate him he is
what America picked so if Congress wants
to be reelected in 2018 they should
think about what the people voted for in
November of 2016 so how is the president
doing how is the Congress doing terrible
how's the president doing he's doing a
fantastic job so far at the Congress not
so fantastic but you know I've I've hope
that we can turn it on what do you think
in the news media well I mean you guys
are fabulous but CNN is fake news what
do you think of CNN
maybe ABC NBC CBS MSNBC how's the
president doing
I think he's doing an absolutely
phenomenal job yeah what do you think of
Congress I think Congress is being I
feel like they're playing the politics
of everything I think each and every
congressman got to understand that look
we got to do what's right for the
country and listen I really come
together yes and I really I really think
that if Congress can come together and
say look you know we're working towards
the better of our of everybody of all
Americans I think we'll be phenomenal
but what about how do you feel about the
news media I think a lot of the news
media is fake except except Hannity you
know you know we loved handy that's
that's a promo I want this promo
obviously president Oh wonderful
I feel better every day what about
Congress what about drain this wall hi
sweetheart what's your name say la now
can you stand back and show everybody
your beautiful dress look at that you
got a Donald Trump dress do you like it
how old do you and you like the
president I love him you love him why
because he does good things for our
country how's the president doing
fantastic good how is the Congress doing
not good I'm president of the
Pennsylvania Motor Truck Association
bless you for what you do I heard you uh
so has business business is very good
we're here to support the president is
is in for this tax plan certainly reduce
corporate and individual tax rates are
going to help our industry it worked for
Reagan it worked for Kennedy why
wouldn't it work now right absolutely
it's gonna need Congress gonna get this
done I hope so I'm cautiously how do you
feel the news media treats the president
you're tired of it
yeah and all of them pretty much yeah
exactly thank you
[Music]